all of this this this march towards
communism is being fueled
by our mainstream media if you don't
believe me we've got about a two-minute
uh compilation video from grabian media
of uh the
lefties and the media cohorts uh pushing
communism enjoy no one likes to mandate
people to do things that they may not
want to do
but sometimes for the greater good of
society
you have to do that you got to start
telling people if you don't get
vaccinated you can't come into this
office or this place of business we
really need to make it clear that there
are privileges associated with being an
american that if you wish to have these
privileges you need to get vaccinated
travel and having the right to travel in
our state it's not a constitutional
right as far as i'm as far as i know
getting vaccinated is not a personal
choice
it's not it's something that we do for
the community i think that he should
approach this with an iron fist if you
don't get vaccinated you can't come to
work people aren't then going to
threaten to go to another workplace if
every workplace has that same
requirement that's a good thing so i
don't think it's overreach i think this
is what's needed in the middle of a
pandemic and in fact i think the body
administration if anything could have
gone even further and those governors
that stand in the way i think it was
very clear from the president's tone
today
that uh he will run over them if you
don't get vaccinated you can't come into
this gym screw your freedom because with
freedom comes applications and
responsibilities your personal choice
ends where my right not to get killed by
an infectious disease begins so we have
these collective actions for the good of
the community not the individual we
don't live in a bubble we live in a
community
and that is why there have been a number
of instances throughout history where we
have made a decision as a society to
abide by common rules that protect the
common good we really have to
you know think in terms of what is best
for society at this point if you don't
get vaccinated you can't come into this
get onto this airplane you can stay
unvaccinated if you want but you're not
going to be able to travel to see your
family we've been patient
but our patience is wearing thin
there you have it the tolerant and
diverse and open and freedom-loving and
honest and decent
lefty media and politicians as you were
watching that how did you feel i mean
really feel like as you were watching
i've now watched it probably 10 times
today
but even on this showing just now it's
like man you feel kind of tense right
it's like there are really
really bad people out there right now
pushing really really bad ideas
and the irony of course the ultimate
irony is if donald trump was president
and donald trump was pushing a federal
vaccine mandate across the entire
country every single one of those lying
sellout buffoons would be saying the
exact same reverse thing not the same
thing they would be saying the complete
reverse thing they would be saying this
is overreach
he's a maniac this is fascism this is
biomedical tyranny they would all be
saying that but they like biden and they
like the power and they like the machine
and scratch a progressive and find a
really hysterical authoritarian okay
that it is just so obvious and arnold
schwarzenegger what do you say screw
your freedom is that what he said screw
your freedom arnold schwarzenegger the
terminator commando
dennis quaid from total recall
like what
god these people what do we do what do
we do as as free decent people like like
just think of the difference of of the
type of people that now exist in the
world i would say you know we can talk
about left right we can talk about
top bottom we can talk about uh you know
conservative liberal we can talk about
all of those things but it's basically
like you've got some people
who want to understand the world and
some people who want to control the
world that's what this is all boiled
down to now and it's becoming
very very obvious to any of us that are
paying attention i don't have all the
answers but i don't think they have all
the answers either so what i want to do
is create a ground that the most freedom
can exist so that we can all make the
choices for ourself that we feel is
right and within that there's going to
be some messiness but you know what
comes with that messiness the
opportunity for human flourishing that's
a freaking beautiful thing that's what
this country was based upon
those people the people that demand you
bow to them the people that you demand
that demand that you not talk about
certain things the people who would
gladly have you fired and silenced and
pushed to the margins of society it's
like they're not the good guys and until
enough of us are willing to say that and
enough of us are willing to say boy it's
getting hot in this pot right now it's
getting pretty hot
you know we better do something before
we all boil it's like they're going to
keep moving they're just going to keep
moving so we have our work cut out for
us as i often say